hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
simultaneous blindfold exhibition that
took place in paris where morphy is
taking on
uh eight uh opponents uh simultaneously
blindfold as um
well you might you might have imagined
and here his opponent is uh well a very
strong player
uh jean lui pretty and somehow someone
mentioned in the comments on the
previous video that the game we've shown
uh the first one from the simultaneous
exhibition against mr pottier
is not the first game that finished uh
when in fact i did say that that was the
first game they finished so i went
to check out in lawson's book and it
says that the games between potty and
pretty are the ones that
finished first so i don't i i don't know
which one of them finished first but i
guess it could also
be this one so let's go with that i'm
going to trust the gentleman that
suggested this in the comments uh let's
say this is the first one and the one
against potty is the one that finished
the second but they were all
both very short so i guess um
that doesn't change anything all that
much but if it's if it's
you know if it's the way that happened i
i guess it's uh fine
uh and unlike for mr potty we have quite
a bit of information about john louis
pretty so i'm going to read a little bit
about him
as well just so you guys know who he was
he was the
well he was a musician and the chess
writer and he specialized in chess
end game so uh he and his son were the
principal editors of the french monthly
chess magazine la strategy
and he was the author of several chess
books uh he was born in mantua
and uh in in 1978 uh sorry in 1798 and
at the age of 28 he was involved in some
political political conspiracy had to
leave his country suddenly uh to escape
the severity of austrian martial law
and he crossed the alps with his young
wife and there uh
he uh soon uh settled in in bordeaux
where he gave music lessons and very
soon became professor at the
royal college but his health slowly uh
gave in and he had to give up this
professorship
and then begins his connection with
chess in france in 1844 he settled
permanently in paris
took part regularly in the weekly
contest at the cafe de la regence
his position in the rank of foremost
parisian players
we find his name frequently mentioned in
the french chess periodicals from 49 to
62
and he was one of the few witnesses of
the ever memorable anderson morphe match
that we are going to cover in length uh
as soon as we
we reach it so a little bit uh about our
good friend generally pretty here as uh
it's hard to say if we will ever uh well
uh
uh uh you know uh get get to him during
the paul morphy saga or any other
saga for that matter so uh it never
hurts to know a little bit
uh so this is the second game we're
showing from the simultaneous exhibition
but it could also very well be the first
game that finished
all together so morphe again with the
white pieces as that's how you
uh do when you are the one holding the
simultaneous exhibition
opens with e4 and here uh pretty goes
for c5 he goes for the sicilian defense
morphe immediately strikes in the center
with the d4 we have c
capture sunday for knight to f3 and now
e5
sort of uh gambiting upon but not really
yeah because uh
here if you captured upon a quinta a5
check just picks up that knight
and although it seems uh uh crazy to
capture this uh pawn with the knight i
actually did this once in
in in a blitz tournament uh some maybe i
don't know
maybe even 12 years ago uh i think it
was the first round of the blitz
tournament i
i tried playing a little bit you know of
the olden openings like immediately
going for that strike in the center with
d4 c3 and so on
uh and then i actually grabbed this
spawn uh because i didn't study any
theory i just saw morphe plays it so
obviously i i should play it as well and
then i blundered the knight
in case you were wondering so after e5
morphe of course doesn't wonder the
knight he goes bishop to c4
continues his rapid development and
bishop to be for
check now so we are now in the smith
mora gambit
we have c3 defending check and now
d captures on c3 and now while you might
expect morphe to go for something like
castles give up some more material uh it
could be
definitely playable but for some reason
he doesn't uh
like it it's very easy for black to you
know blend or something if d6 queen b3
attacks the bishop and the f7 pawn
it's going to be a very hard position to
play for black so instead after this
morphe just recapture so we have b
captures in c3
and now bishop to c5 uh there is one
game in the database uh
sort of a newer date where d5 was played
but bishop to c5
is in even better move even though it
dates the you know
1858 and it is as of move 6 that this
position has never been reached again
so here we have knight captures on e5
already morphy is threatening to capture
on f7
uh the position was never reached again
for good reasons uh and the queen to f6
now we have
a counter attack the f6 seven point is
hanging but also
queen captures and f2 will be checkmate
if it occurs so here
bishop captures with check king to f8
and now we have this uh pretty crazy
position here also from the thumbnail we
can do it like this sort of a little
arrow here something like maybe maybe
red here
uh where you know good things can happen
but also bad things can happen so it's a
very interesting position
what would you play here feel free to
pause the video and try to find
the correct way to continue this game
for morphe while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not doing
anything weird
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show uh f4
is fine here it prevents checkmate and
also guards uh the knight here on e5
uh but even stronger is knight to d3
this is what morphy played and now
white simply has a really really great
advantage this is defended
this is attacked and you don't care
about queen captures on f7 even though
this is the
best move for for black if characters
capture so you're just going to continue
developing
uh and uh well black's king side is just
ruined if something like queen to c4
going after
the knight uh and uh maybe stopping uh
for
stopping um uh from castling just bishop
f4
beautiful i mean if queen captures
bishop d6 check picks up the queen it's
just uh awesome stuff
so well well this is best for black
black decides that uh
he's not interested in that he goes
bishop back to b6
and now morphy retreats with the bishop
bishop to b3 and he keeps this monster
bishop alive
we have knight to c6 by black uh still
uh f2 is a target so if he can somehow
get rid of this knight maybe 95
maybe capture maybe you know uh queen
captures an f2 maybe he can still check
mate morphy with bishop the a3 check
d6 blocking and now castles by morphe
so now morphe takes care of any uh
immediate checkmating threats and is now
ready to continue his attack so
tonight's the h6
uh pretty has to play something and now
morphe just continued his onslaught uh
e5 and this is awesome you cannot
capture here the bishop is spinning the
pawn that the queen cannot capture
because knight captures so what else can
you play here
you could go for knight captures but
still after for example if knight
captures uh
do you really want to capture with the
queen here bishop captures on d6
again you blunder your queen so it's a
very ugly position to defend so after e5
we have queen to g6 by pretty instead
constantly planning some devious ideas
here maybe this knight can also help
out uh with the you know checkmating of
the white king so
we'll see what happens we have knights
to f4 putting pressure on the queen here
and the queen to g for now attacking
this knight and now
there are many ways to win this game and
for example just queen captures and d6
is perfectly fine
there's really not a lot you can do here
you have to go to e8 and then
just knight d5 and you slowly creep in
on on the black king
but the move morphy plays is just to
show off he he's like uh
yeah this is win this wins but even
though i'm blindfolded and playing
against
uh eight people simultaneously i'm still
just gonna play this move
give me one second
[Music]
ah no it's not the mailman it's yelena
uh so after this queen to g4 move like i
said we could go for some
uh action here but morphy just goes
knight to e6 with
check and it looks like he's giving up a
piece but not really black's composition
is completely shattered
and look i mean look at the bishops here
it's been a while since we had a bishop
pair from hell such as this one
so here there really is no good move for
black whatever you play
you're just getting destroyed so black
accepted bishop captures an e6 but now
queen captures on d6 with check now with
a double attack on the bishop
king to f7 only way to to keep in the
game because just bishop captures would
win
and now queen to d7 checked by morphy
the bishop is pinned of course so you
cannot capture
and if you go if you of course move the
king somewhere that doesn't work just
captures and you're getting checkmated
very quickly also you lose the queen
so after this check we have king to g6
very ugly but
what are you gonna do and now bishop
captures an e6 by morphy attacking the
queen here
queen to g5 and now even bishop to d5
going after some uh very nasty tricks
here uh and
there really is no good move here knight
captures and e5 was played but now
bishop to e4 check we have knight to f5
and now queen to e6 with
check queen to f6 defending and now
bishop captures an f5 of course uh the
king or the queen are
unable to recapture so you have to move
king to h5 was played
but now just g4 with check and again
there is no good move here whatever you
play uh you can't really move the king
if you move the king king to h4 or king
to h6
either bishop e7 wins because uh you
lose
the queen or bishop to c1 check just
ends the game on the spot again the
queen will have to block and that's it
so this bishop really a mighty piece
here
being able to reach all of these squares
is just just a monster
uh so here uh knight captures on g4 was
played there really isn't
anything better here and now comes
bishop captures with
check king to g5 and here morphy just
played bishop to e7 with
the final pin that wins the game and it
was in this position on move 25 that
jean-luc pretty resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
so really really a wild one obviously
the one that
finished first so now we we have two
games that finished first and this was
uh
uh i mean it seems like white was
completely
winning uh straight from the beginning
but i mean uh
from this position here okay uh a queen
of six it does seem like black
maybe could do something especially you
know you're facing morphe for the first
time and he's blindfolded surely
you know good things will happen for you
but nope no
they will not uh so that's the game the
second one that we've shown for
from this famous fair paris blindfolded
simultaneous exhibition hope you guys
enjoyed it and uh well
it was quite a game uh i would like to
thank uh
sarah sanger uh mikhail keller uh misha
dumou
uh uh mao mara mao unleashes and alex
s for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage
of the morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh he just
you know
jumped so uh i got startled uh so yeah
uh thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day